And I know it's easy to sit here, obviously,
and blame the Democrats because they are in
charge of the House of Representatives, but
we also cannot discount the role that Republicans
are playing in all of this after all Republicans,
at least on the surface, don't want any kind
of accountability for Donald Trump whatsoever.
Let the man be just let him do what he's gonna
do.
Right.
Well, actually there are some Republicans
who are starting to get annoyed by the fact
that the president seems to think he in his
cabinet and his officials are all above the
law.
Very rare, very few.
But there are some, and I'm not just talking
about a Republican representative, Justin
Amash, there's others.
According to a new report by political here
you have representative Ken Buck.
You have representative Tom Cole, you have
representative Mike Simpson, and of course
representative Amash.
Those are four Republicans who even though
they may not be happy with the Democrats in
their investigations into Donald Trump, they
have also expressed their concern over the
fact that the president refuses to comply
with any of these investigations along with
the other people from his office.
So again, uh, Ken Buck from Colorado, Tom
Cole from Oklahoma, Mike Simpson from Idaho
and Justin Amash from Michigan are all Republican
members of the House of Representatives who
were starting to get fed up with the president.
And this is according to a report in politico.
Here's what this means because believe it
or not, there is some good that comes out
of this story.
It shows us that there are cracks in the facade
that people within the Republican Party who
actually hold positions of power, meaning
US representative.
They're starting to wonder why the president
is behaving this way.
They're starting to say publicly that this
isn't okay.
And whether or not he agrees with the investigations,
whether or not I agree with the investigations,
he has to do this.
He is not above the law, unfortunately.
One of their big fears that they have is not
just about Trump.
It's about setting the precedent for future
presidents to ignore any and all investigations
or document requests or subpoenas coming from
the House of Representatives.
See, so now the truth kind of starts to unravel
a little bit.
It's not just that, oh, we want Trump to comply
and behave.
It's, no, no, no, no, no.
We're looking into the future and eventually
we know we're gonna have another Democratic
president and we may want to investigate them
and we want them to cooperate.
But if Trump doesn't, and the courts rule,
he doesn't have to, then by Golly, we're never
going to be hold to be able to hold another
Democrat accountable ever again.
So the truth comes out a little bit, right?
These republicans aren't necessarily worried
that Donald Trump is ruining the reputation
of the presidency, or that he's completely
disregarding the law and acting like he is
above it.
No, they're worried that their future attempts
to go after Democrats are going to fail based
on what Donald Trump is doing today.
But I guess you got to take an ally wherever
you can get them right.
Because if these are saying that Donald Trump
needs to comply, we kind of have to say, okay,
we agree with you.
We don't agree with your long game here, but
we need allies or do we?
And that's another question we have to answer.
Do we need these Republican allies with ulterior
motives?
Because we don't actually, when you look at
the numbers, the Democrats don't need any
republicans to join with them in the House
of Representatives for impeachment.
We already have the numbers.
We can make it happen.
The place we need allies is in the Senate.
And that ain't never going to happen.
I ain't even Mitt Romney who's wagging his
finger at Donald Trump telling him, oh, you're
doing horrible things.
He still admit freely that I don't think impeachments
the way to go.
We're not gonna do that.
So once again, we have another Jeff flake
in the Senate this time.
It just happens to be Mitt Romney, but mid,
I got to put it to you this way, bud.
What if it's a big, if, what if you were to
join in with Democrats and maybe get a couple
of your other Republicans over to their side
so you could vote to convict and removed from
office in the Senate and then suddenly, oh,
there might be room for a Republican challenger
to Mike Pence in the 2020 primaries.
Oh, that seems like the perfect opportunity
for a guy like Mitt Romney to jump into the
presidential race.
Right?
So just, just think about it mid, right?
You wanted to be president.
I'm sure you still want to be president.
If you didn't, you wouldn't have run for Senate.
You still have ambitions, you still have goals,
but there is one man standing in your way
and that man happens to be Donald Trump.
But you, if you get enough allies in the Senate,
you could absolutely do something about that.
Mike Pence is a pushover.
He is not popular or charismatic enough to
win a primary.
So Mitt, just a little bit of friendly advice
there.
Uh, for the record, I do not want you to be
president of the United States.
I think you would be just as bad as Donald
Trump.
He just wouldn't be as a brace of on the outside.
But I'm just saying, I know you're ambitious,
so follow your ambition and do the right thing
in this one instance because you could.
But as for these other folks in the House
of Representatives who are saying, Oh, Donald
Trump is frustrating cause he's not obeying
the law.
Keep in mind that while they may be saying
that now, it's not because they're mad at
Trump, it's because they're mad.
They may not be,
be able to hold a future Democrats counted.
We need to take another quick break and you
right back with more the David Pakman show